hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play outlast
ok we just escaped from - maniacal
maniacs who wanted to match our brains
into mush and then I don't know suck it
through a straw or something so we need
to keep going Oh what's with that means
all they're still chasing me ok well I
thought I was in oh crap hey buddy stop
that now I thought it was in the clear
for this hang in there but apparently
not well your money I didn't give you
any money I need my camera on for this
close it close it close it close I do
want to live can I get in please thank
you if you think you think you think
there are we go goodbye they wanted to
nibble on my raisins going aren't you
oh he's witness or whatever you must be
exhausted
yeah you'll do a martini lunch ok what
have you say bloody thanks you so funny
I can't even stand it I think I'm gonna
die from laughter uh-huh uh-huh
can I have my camera back it's very
valuable it's pretty expensive I'm a
reporter
I'm Nason Murdoch or whatever the heck
my name was i'm markiplier if you didn't
know famous on youtube you know kinda a
little bit not really famous
of here at night Oh No
yeah go ahead I'll wait here okay come
on any no hurry no
last clue you hose to the grindstone I
like that okay hey you're kind of one of
those insane e psycho doctors ain't you
are you dr. Wernicke but dead and alive
somehow I have no idea your nails are
kind of long there hello Doctor I know
that wall is very interesting but I'd
like to speak with you about something
oh yes follow the trail blood the
wheelchair trail of blood if I'm not
mistaken
[Music]
I don't think
quickly not turn any use anyway pretty
total time is just trying to look at the
stance what does that even mean what am
I gonna have to lick where we are
thanks so much for coming behind we'll
begin your consultation in one emerges
all right my camera movies give us a
chance to talk oh good you're gonna
record me being tortured nice booty oh
[Music]
now I'm struggling really I didn't
struggle when he was holier than thou
bible something of course not no offense
to the man but if I had the oculus rift
alright God died with concrete murder in
it is the simplest form but what happens
when all the man is gone I don't know
what are you gonna do okay thank you oh
yes
pull the giant knife out of the toilet
those are scissors
[Music]
oh my god not all of them just two of
them oh good then why wouldn't you
struggle before all he did was punch you
oh god man yeah now you're out Wow
congratulations come on man what are you
doing hold it together come on man
seriously what kind of guy could get out
of that so each I mean I understand
adrenaline but he hit you in the head
it's not like he knocked you out
you didn't even struggle when he was
putting you in the chair what the heck I
mean I know he's kind of ripped but he
doesn't look that strong and why would
he just leave I don't get it
okay taking solace nobody's coming now
I'm not trying to okay I didn't even see
him coming there okay then let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
Oh No and all the giant piles of blood
and then we go oh okay run oh man this
is messed up I don't even know what's
going on here there's all sorts of
messed up oh just piles up body parts
that must be that doctor that was in
that note there's that guy with the
stitched up face again a weirdo psycho
bonkers crazy I have no idea what is
going on here
hello
I mean a nama hello what's going on here
how about it are you doing you actually
look kind of normal
I'm not the doctor it looks like you're
in C Oh where'd you come from doc come
on
it blocked me off this crazy doctors
insane all right then let's see what
happens here
oh that's a good surprise I guess you've
popped out after I talked to the gun
whoa hi
where'd you come from open track doc
don't open slow up and fast
oh okay where am I going oh no oh no oh
no get out of getting together get
together get together you there was a
way he came from I don't know where
though oh where did he come from where
did he go where did he come from
cotton-eye Joe I think I need to push
that there was another thing oh no oh no
oh no come on yeah sick move bruh okay
I'm gonna lose him in this area I'm
gonna make another loop and I'm gonna
close the door on him and then I'm going
to try to push that out of the way it
might just give me enough closer Lam
come on me bro me bro good to go you
come in for me bro oh no don't tell me
you're you've got good pathfinding
skills and you're going the other way
Oh close thank you got here f off and
back okay I think I can get to the other
place and close it and Ja setup time
close it oh yeah now push it butyou to
the limit [ __ ] [ __ ] you a hold
bouche it harder okay there we go open
it here we go alright and into the
elevator oh no I didn't get the key I
get the key
oh no oh no wait did he open that door
the door wasn't open before where's the
key what am I going to find the key
where am I suppose by Nicky is he gone
did he leave
oh my god holy crap oh oh he can
intelligently open doors how nice is
that
well-well just oh crap I went the wrong
place this guy's kind of smarter than
the others
Howie he stabbed me in the butt he's the
butt stabber
I knew it it'll slow him down for like a
fraction of a second cuz he needs some
politely and calmly open doing
I gotta find wherever the heck this some
he is which I'm assuming maybe I can
push through here come on push push push
much harder and much faster than that
much harder and much Roger and much
magic okay oh thank you
okay is there a key in here turkey in
here
how much want to know I can barely see
anything with everything huh no money
there's no key in here is there
it's so cute here there's nothing in
here there's nothing in there oh he's
actually trying to bash that one down
come at me bro I'm ready ready for you
come on Luke Lukey Luke
loop-de-loop
it's gotta be a way it's gotta be oh
shut up a hole Trager is that your name
you son of a [ __ ] no way I could quit
he's got this weird like wave speaking
Li with a little bit of a list nobody
likes a quitter oh I see got you nobody
likes a quitter
all right so he's somewhere I'm pretty
sure he's not far behind
ah hello where did he got here time to
read this is my third time asking for
reassignment after two months without an
answer I don't want to work at Mount
massive anymore I have been an orderly
in my entire adult life but have never
experienced such a consistent level of
secrecy and disrespect I even have
suspicions that some of the patients may
be being abused I know personally of two
of them who have been moved to the
basement Ward never returned if I don't
get an answer to this email I will be
forced to resign and may well very well
consider contacting the press thank for
your time David Annapurna is that the
guy that contacted me in the beginning
Oh
oh no that was just the thing okay so I
got it wait a minute this look familiar
is this where I was in the beginning
oh no get out of here not there barely
how do I get back out there I don't
think I know I just locked myself into
my own doom Oh what am I good hi hey
buddy oh that's out gonna be crap where
do I go
oh no I come the way he came okay that's
right
I'm good all right so this must at some
point lead back to the elevator right
right right right am i right
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh I'm so
out of here I'm so out of here
bye-bye I'm going down stab yourself in
the face
is he like actually dead or what can i
grab the knife and make sure are you
dead you dead bro what to do now oh I
get it
you better actually be dead that's all I
have to say cuz I'm losing tooth
I've lost two fingers and you're in a
hole ah ha nice uh boo - sorry no time
for the booty gotta get going
wait isn't this just where I was before
or this wait a minute can I get out this
way I go up or go down let's go up first
nope up was wrong
down is correct I might actually be
getting close to the end but I haven't
exactly unlocked the secret of Project
walrider so I don't think I'm that close
to being their battery back here yeah
thank you just needed a new one right
now all right take this off go over here
what have we got what have we got
teamwork ha ha ha ah Patrick Petrina
Petrina
okay so now that that heart attack of a
situation is over it's gonna all calm
down and then I'm gonna run into those
two big naked guys all right my fav E or
the big guy this is a quite a long week
hey what's going on what's going on okay
close to what Project walrider which is
gonna rip my intestines out through my
nose okay whatever
into the dark again into the dark dark
why is why is these body parts on fire
why and why is there a camera there what
were people doing here do I want to know
I don't think I want to know okay then
that's a little strange but you know
whatever whatever man
whatever floats your boat and it's dark
it's dark it's
okay
okay I actually think that this might be
a good time to stop because we'll
section off the whole horrible dr. chase
scene into one episode so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation more videos in I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]